welcome back to las vegas now regenerate
medical concierge the sponsors of this
next segment are here to help men
optimize their health especially those
feeling testosterone deficient check it
out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm dr amin and this is regenerate
medical concierge my practice where we
do iv therapy and anti-aging treatments
it's commonly thought that anti-aging
health and wellness is mostly aimed at
women not quite true we do plenty of
different things for men here as well
one of the big ones is men's health
which is primarily testosterone
replacement therapy
men tend to think that it's quite a
tedious process to get started in health
and wellness and optimizing their own
bodies
the reality of it is it's actually quite
a simple process in our office here when
men come in we give them a simple
questionnaire that has a list of
symptoms once i review that if they do
fit the profile then we take it to the
next step and do an interview with the
patient and come to a conclusion on
dosing and medications lab work etc some
of the things we look at on the
questionnaire is if they've noticed that
they've shortened in their height or
their decreased energy stamina or
decreases in libido or an inability to
climax during a sexual intercourse
patient safety is one of our biggest
concerns especially when it comes to
men's health using testosterone which is
a controlled substance and we pride
ourselves on that safety component in
the office here and in an attempt to do
that we do check labs
numerous times throughout the year while
also monitoring levels of the
testosterone and other labs that are
directly affected by testosterone the
process is relatively simple for men
when they come in they take the
questionnaire i look over the answers
and if they do qualify we do the lab
work and they get their first
testosterone injection that day it's a
quick and painless process of coming in
weekly to get the booster injection as
long as they let us know in advance that
they're coming we have everything ready
they get their booster shot and they can
usually be in and out in a few minutes
so
if you're a man out there and you've
taken the questionnaire or you've seen
what we've talked about today and you
think you might be a candidate feel free
to call us or come and visit us at
regenerate medical concierge we're
located at the district at gvr
[Music]
thank you to regenerative medical
concierge for sponsoring that segment
for more information just call
702-998-8009 or head to regenerate
regeneratemedicalconcierge.com